[Musique]
alors ce soir envie de commencer en
citant de yann moix via de maxxo
effectivement l'humanité a perdu 100
points de clients sans temps ça se voit
la preuve avec le laurier du pire de la
télé réalité38 battlo donc c'est vrai
que je faisais écouter ma tête je n'y
aurais déjà et qui me dit mme carla
vas-y doucement state britain
et puis j'attends de voir il va falloir
résolu les problèmes de juillet vous
allez vous d'ébruiter et en a qui se
mettent en couple et y en a qui quiron
peut-être sur les balais m bagdad accusé
de 2,3 ripaille bon du tout comme ça je
n'y connais ma à aucun moment j'ai
séduit
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est-ce que j'ai tous les gars
cadre d'objectifs ainsi donc c'est bon
il bénéficie pas comme julia est très
bon très bon alors même si je le taquine
un petit peu je suis un grand fan de
william leymergie celui qui je me suis
levé tous les matins pendant des années
sur france 2 il y avait qui désormais je
mange tous les midis sur ces 8
vous savez que les sujets abordés dans
son émission sont toujours très engagé
alors je vous remets à william à midi le
laurier de l'émission qui continue de
traiter les sujets les plus chauds du
moment
savez-vous maintenant comment faire
sécher votre linge de manière efficace
d'union à parler maintenant de vos
animaux domestiques en particulier des
chiens hyperactif il existe près de 15
cents variétés de bambous un débile
c'est très important de bien choisir sa
hotte je vous la propose oui on tiède ou
froide c'est la madeleine alors quand il
eut l'idée de ce thème très clivant de
la madeleine
après avoir entendu la question la plus
sans concession le démangeait madeleine
mais qui tous les dida
[Applaudissements]
alors il ya un homme dont je vous parle
souvent ici c'est pascal praud long de
l'émission de débats lors des pros sur
ses news
pour ceux qui connaissent pas cette
émission c'est comme william à midi avec
des sujets intéressants j'en ai je vous
tire tu dis ce que tu veux mais je sais
que tu tu vas tout le monde je veux tout
le monde et vous le savez que vous allez
voir encadré
alors parce qu'elle a encore eu du mal
parce qu'elle poids encore eu du mal à
gérer ses chroniqueurs qui seront encore
plus surexcités qu'ici et vous allez
comprendre pourquoi je remets le laurier
de l'animateur le plus schizophrène de
la télévision française
alors on se souvient que pascal points
et beaucoup de mal à dire le mot marre
ça veut dire quoi un choix assez bien
cette semaine il est encore plus demain
avec ses chroniqueurs 14 minutes après
le début de l'émission il est déjà sous
les alors il balance son stylo mais pas
alors une nuit et après il faut déjà
arrêter l'émission
les gens disent et inaudible on arrête
ces grandes antennes on arrête ces
nuisibles les indiens les hauts talons
rendent antennes alors le comprend parce
qu'à une meuf qui peut pas blairer la
petite fille isabelle morini bosc à ces
questions vous parler tout seul depuis
toujours donc comme ça qu'est ce qu'on
peut vous répondre
comment les pelouses où l'époux d'une
personnalité
comme vous syrie il se ferait avec ses
chroniqueurs de mieux d'après il chante
deux mois les dom dakar
fort c'est que vous l'avez un cédric si
des rebonds la tournée ce genre d soir
est gentil si tu as d'autres alors
chaque semaine je remets le lauréat ou
tard baba à celui qui a le plus tacler
ses collègues dans l'émission et chaque
semaine pour le vainqueur et à peu près
autant de suspense pour les audiences
d'europe 1 alors à votre avis est-ce que
l'on entrevoit réussi à détrôner
l'animal impossible moi je sais pas vous
vouler savoir on gars le soir même et
bien cette semaine le tabac c'est
évidemment cyril hanouna au départ par
le par le jeune j'ai fait de la télé on
va trouver tout de suite plus beauf quoi
ca way back home / r c'est sûr que c'est
que l'année prochaine les gens
trouveront pas beau benjamin
[Rires]
mination totalement logique parce qu'ils
étaient ratés sur les deux dernières
épreuves
il est sorti sur un million de paris
j'avais fait ma wishlist de tous les
sites avec qui je joue avec qui je
voulais bosser web et il s'appelle est
aussi wish list et malheureusement ils
sont tous au sahara doc gynéco passer
une belle soirée magnifique c'est pas
difficile de passer la soirée à regarder
la télé de payer
finir j'avance cédric je me suis
toujours donc demandé ce que vous
donneriez si vous présentiez des
éditions la place d'animateur qui est
complètement à l'opposé du vôtre y en a
beaucoup
alors pour vérifier je vais essayer de
vous faire entrer dans les cordes par
exemple de stéphane bern et jean pierre
pernaut en échangeant vos voix c'est le
switch c'est nouveau c'est nouveau ça
vient de sortir des problèmes avec son
ami vous me connaissez si bien et
pourtant votre santé il faut avoir non
vraiment une raie des fesses
irréprochable oui non et oui
effectivement j'ai envie de savoir
comment vous dormi dedans parce que
c'est vrai que la nuit quand il fait
chaud on se demande comment va dormir
vous dormez en pyjama oui bien entendu
mais le grand vainqueur du jour pour
l'instant le champion c'est bien sûr le
singe qui a le cul qui grave on va
passer maintenant au japonais petter
[Applaudissements]